e aí galera que assistiu ao canal todo
bom você e domingo agora dia das mães né
das mães é uma data muito feliz um
mandato que todo mundo gosta ela imagina
para uma mãe como é que seria chegando o
dia das mães ea filha dela está no
hospital o risco de morte é todo dia é o
que está acontecendo como ainda flavina
esses dias antes de vir para teresina
morava na cidade chamada bom jesus está
crescendo acaraú onde mora o meu pai ea
minha mãe é onde a minerva está com
vocês o dia pergunta minha cachorrinha
tarde a fab ela mora lá o que aconteceu
a medula da flávia parou de produzir
aqui então todo dia fala que os seios de
cinco bolsas de sangue cinco bolsas de
sangue para uma pessoa só todos os dias
e os remédios que está tomando é muito
muito caro eu fico pensando na família
quando era criança eu estava brincando
com a peteca pt tinha é bilac chama e
criança quando é pequeno gosta de
colocar as coisas na boca em face de
televisão como que a pequena bom eu
deitei no sofá que eu deitei no sofá em
gaza e que o cptec eu nunca nunca nunca
vou esquecer na minha vida a expressão
do meu pai quando ele me viu em aberto
em setembro agora sim me dá até uma
coisa ruim olhar meu pai meu e ele
ficava falando em meu deus meu filho em
salvar meu filho meu filho meu fiador de
um pai e uma mãe perder um filho é tudo
gente dorme apertar e foram apertando
até que um jogo é peteca pra fora de
engasgar e o meu pai teve aquele
sofrimento de poder perder um filho
assim por mais ou menos uns 30 segundos
imagina a mãe o pai da flec todo dia
todo
convive com o medo dela mulher qualquer
momento e faltar remédio de faltar o
sangue eu queria pedir a vocês e não
como eles o humorista não como eles o
comediante não como ele é isso que faz
vídeos na internet eu queria pedir a
você como isso que um dia vai ser pai um
dia vai se preocupar com o filho que tem
se um dia ele precisar de uma ajuda e se
um dia ele precisar o inglês um painel é
fazer tudo que ele puder para ajudar
aqui na descrição do vídeo tem a conta
do pai de flávio eu sei que tem muitas
têm muitas pessoas são menores de idade
que me assiste a falar eu não posso
ajudar porque eu não sei fazer um
depósito não posso ajudar porque minha
mãe não deixa o cara mostra esse vídeo
com a sua mãe morre esse vídeo com o seu
pai
eu tenho certeza que ele vai saber o que
é isso que estou falando você fala pai
vamos lá comigo no banco pai por favor
faz isso pra mim a pessoa que ela é pai
que ela é mãe ela espera até o último
segundo com esperança aquele dinheiro
que você ir lanchar manhã na escola e
cinco reais você deixa o jogador na
gaveta pai vamos lá você vai estar na
esperança um pai tirar filho do hospital
e voltar à vida normal e ver a filha se
formar ea filha se casar e ter filho da
unep com o pai você vê esse vídeo fala
senão vídeos e bonitinho de internet a
legal vou compartilhar que não quer que
eu vou fazer vou agora no banco e vocês
vão comigo e eu vou depositar o que
vinte reais e 20 reais
somente a carteira vamos lá vamos lá
vamos lá
o
aí está o erro foi o mesmo
você pode tirar foto comigo olha agora
é
pronto acabei de sair do banco fiz que o
comprovante em favor dos haitianos e
kipron deixei o meu almoço pra poder
depositar então vai lá e faz
então pegue o seu pai bem com você
lembrando que ela também precisa de
sangue se você aqui de teresina é só
você ver o endereço que está aqui a
descrição do vídeo você vai lá doar
sangue e direciona o nome dela você vai
estar ajudando muito se você gostou
desse vídeo não precisa fazer nada se
você sentir que dá um gosto vai ajudar
eu gostei de você sentir que quer
comentar alguma coisa comigo você sentir
que você deve compartilhar esse vídeo
compartilhe que você vai está ajudando
muito tá muito obrigado você assistir se
vir até aqui e
ninguém
a mãe